the quotes in sports illustrated if they
were uttered by anybody
in this draft not named trevor lawrence
with without a doubt
would give many people pause like his uh
high school coach saying well you know
he could quit football now and that's no
big deal
you know and he's got nothing to prove
according to trevor lawrence if it was
attributed to justin fields there would
be five alarm fires
in every single spot and the talon
valley talent evaluation community and
then the media on top of it
if josh rosen had said those things just
a couple of years ago
same deal so
what does make trevor lawrence tick and
all of that
and the conversations that have come out
of the peace and sports illustrated
written by michael rosenberg who joins
us here right now how are you sir
i am great greetings from a little town
called ann arbor michigan i think you're
familiar with
you look at you so
that is pretty cool um thank you for
that
i appreciate that how did you get uh
to know trevor lawrence or cross paths
with him or
when did you first do that to gain the
trust
for the access that you received in this
piece michael
uh you know uh it was in an ongoing
uh discussion with the agency which is
how this usually goes and and just kind
of i didn't really know where the story
was going
until i started talking to people i
didn't know a ton about him for someone
who's been in the spotlight that long
it was kind of weird because i was
listening to the tape of the interview
and i swear my first question
was about this very topic of you don't
seem like you've got that chip on your
shoulder so i don't
i don't remember might have been his
parents or his high school coach who had
said something that that
that said that but uh i i thought what
was telling to me was that he didn't
mind i said to him i was like you know
people are gonna take this wrong way
he's like yeah i know i don't really
care and i told him what the story would
be
and and he was fine with it so uh
i didn't really know how people would
react i'm not sure how urban meyer would
react but
uh he is who he is and he's pretty
comfortable with it so um
how long did you spend with him how
often how would you
what'd you do uh well we did the photo
shoot
and the video and then i was about an
hour interview and
a couple questions um that i asked him
later on with that and i talked to his
parents and his brother for a while
his brother i could have just kept
talking to for weeks i would say he was
a lot of fun um and and
you know i just went back and forth uh
until you know you do a story like this
it's not about um
you know it's just about trying to kind
of portray people as they are and if
they're comfortable with how they are
then usually
everybody is kind of pleased with the
result and and i have not heard back but
but i felt like i portrayed him as he
was okay and so who is he
he is just somebody who loves football
has always loved every aspect of it and
is not motivated by
anger he's not motivated by insecurity
by fear he just
likes playing and and you know i think
for anyone who's kind of
successful in their career you know for
most of us that feel like we've been
successful
you have that stretch i'd say when
you're starting out where you kind of
you might see enemies all over the place
and eventually you get to this place
where you're like you know what i know
what i'm doing i'm comfortable with
who i am and it kind of becomes process
over result and i just think trevor
lawrence for whatever reason
got to that place about 10 years before
most other people do
uh which i think is refreshing now what
that bodes for his nfl career
10 years down the road and nobody really
knows that i kind of raised that
question in the piece you know i mean if
he's had
several concussions and broken bones and
he it hurts to get up in the morning is
he going to say my life would be better
off without football i mean i think he's
more likely to say that
uh than someone who says they live and
die with it and can't imagine life
without it but i don't assume that will
happen either i would just have to see
mike michael rosenberg senior writer of
sports illustrated here on the rich
eisen show and
that's part of this whole deal with the
the talent evaluation
portion of the nfl calendar as i've seen
it over the years at two decades damn
now uh and the hand ringing like you
know it could he be the next andrew luck
does he really even love football
you know all of that like the
conversations that you hear uh when it
involves wide receivers linebackers
corners
tackles or we're just like well they're
smart
they're into other things than football
can we really trust like that guy who's
gonna stick with the program for five
ten years for that evaluation and it
just drives me nuts so now here's
somebody who's like yeah
you know um i'm not motivated by
having to prove anything and you know
high school coach like yeah
like football is important to him but
it's not the end of everything
it's refreshing to hear but the fact
that there's no blowback is because why
what we've seen over the last several
years from clemson
right michael yes exactly he
he said there's there are not questions
about his ability to play and that's why
he can kind of say this and
not worry that he's going to you know
end up being the 25th pick instead of
the first page right
he's too good so he can say it and and
and i think
he'll never say that but obviously he
knows that you know he knows what he's
done he knows where he's going he knows
uh the power i guess that he has over
his own career
uh and when you have that kind of power
you almost don't have to exercise it you
can just kind of let it sit there and
everybody knows and that was the sense i
got problem is
you know he's just he's not worried
about it because whatever anyone says
about this is not going to affect his
career
so how do you think gleaned from
just makeup and the conversation that
you had how how do you think
he is going to handle losing uh
especially since he's got a head coach
who's not used to it either
how do you think that's going to work
michael well it's where
he has never lost really i mean going
back to high school which is i know
that's true of of a number of guys that
that go to top programs but it's it's
kind of extreme in his case
and yet when i talked to him about the
the occasions when he did lose and you
could really kind of go over every
single game in the last seven years
because there just weren't that many
losses
you know he's kind of okay by the time
his his head hits the pillow that night
and i think that's sort of the the being
at peace with himself
um he kind of it's weird he said he
really believes they're going to win
all the way at the end of the game and
then sometimes looks back uh as with the
playoff game this year and thinks well
obviously that was that was over before
i thought it was but he still kind of
believes and then when it ends
he's okay knowing he'd put everything
into it so i wouldn't worry about how
trevor lawrence is going to handle
losing i would definitely worry about
how urban meyer is going to handle
losing
uh and i think urban meyer knows that
and he's worried about that but i think
trevor is going to be okay
yeah i mean uh there's really nothing
that um
you know that leaps out at you with
anything remotely close to a red flag
at all so basically what jacksonville's
getting is a supremely
gifted individual who
doesn't take anything personally off the
field
to his personal life and focuses like a
champ when it comes time to be a
professional is that
really what the jacksonville jaguars are
going to get michael
yeah i think that's exactly what they're
getting i think they're getting somebody
who's
who's coming in with probably the
ability
and the maturity of somebody who's been
in the league for five or ten years
and that's that that's a hard thing to
find obviously and
and everybody knows about how good he is
so uh the big thing for jacksonville
i i think as it relates to comments in
these stories but also just as it
relates on the field it's the same thing
you got to protect your quarterback
right and and don't let him
be in that position andrew luck was in
where he's saying i have just
had my body destroyed this isn't worth
it anymore i mean it's going to happen
to some degree because it's football but
uh just protect him be happy you got him
be happy that
uh i'm not gonna mention the team
because it'll hurt your feelings
end up with a newborn pick and and and
and see how far you can take this ride
what about the sense that if the
that up that team that you just said
shall not be mentioned
uh had gotten him the sense was that he
you know he in new york wouldn't have
been a great
fit did you get any sense of that at all
you know i i don't really understand
that confuses me a little because then
there are there are guys that go to new
york is as we know
who enjoy it a little too much right and
they're on the back page all the time
and they're on page six and
and it's an issue so now you've got a
guy who's you know
21 just got married uh it doesn't have
the the most active social life just
love football and get along with people
i don't understand
to me that's that's somebody who can
handle new york you know i i don't know
if he would
love it i think he would figure it out i
mean
i i don't i don't think that would have
been as big an issue to me the guys that
are going to be
in trouble there like i think i look at
baker mayfield can you imagine with all
the comments he's made
uh that relationship with the media and
he's obviously had some issues in
cleveland
how that would go in new york like
that's the kind of person that to me
would struggle in new york even though
he would say he loves it i think someone
like trevor lawrence
who doesn't need that spotlight actually
would do quite well there i mean jets
fans would have bought stuff off his
wedding registry like the jacksonville
fans have done
i mean they would have done that i love
it i love how he registered
as though he cannot afford new sheets
well i mean it's that's just a normal
thing for people to do
you know what i mean like you know like
let's just
be normal that's what people who get
married it's certainly when you're age
21 you know i i know that not 21 year
olds aren't about to go
hit it in terms of a massive guaranteed
contract with
huge potential nine figure if not 10 if
it all goes right earning potential
but it just seems like for what your
piece is and
just seems like a normal dude who's
going to duvall county
and it's going to be the hopes of a fan
base that's fervent
in their love for the team and and he'll
become an international star too man
because as you know jacksonville has got
a a large footprint in london
with their owner in those international
games no doubt about it
like it's a good spot for him it seems
yeah i think it is i don't think
you know again it's in the story but i
don't think he was too caught up with
where he was going i don't think he's
too caught up in
in all that stuff and you know the other
part of this i mean he's going to change
i mean
everybody changes over time and and what
form that takes
uh i can't really say but but i i would
be more comfortable taking him than than
a lot of the guys that you see come in
that
that have all these other issues or
unresolved insecurities and all these
things i mean i feel like
it's about as close to a sure thing as
you can get uh personality wise is
trevor lawrence well i just remember
i think i might have learned it right
there on that in that city michael
rosenberg sports illustrated michael
rosenberg couple minutes left with him
uh i might have learned it in that city
that you're calling me from ann arbor
michigan
um where i was taught when you're
writing something
um it's usually too long and you need to
cut something down and the first thing
you should look for is something that
you think
is so crucial to the piece or it's your
favorite story
or your favorite aspect of a piece you
should remove that i think the phrase is
called it's your little darlings when
you're writing something so what was
that for this piece
is there something that hit the floor
that you want to give us right here
i i would say probably an hour an hour
and a half into my conversation with his
brother chase i finally have to say
i'm just going to be clear this story is
not actually about you
because i could have done it i mean he's
just
he's he's just a lot of fun i mean i
know he looks like a character but uh i
just love that he just
and i did squeeze this in there he's
like i i understand these people he's
like i like football now i enjoy it but
i i can't understand these people that
watch the game and they don't know
somebody who's playing you know and i
i'm thinking raja gadda must be happy
that there is an audience out there that
does
not need to know the players personally
uh to buy tickets or watch on tv because
that would that would hurt the revenue
so
uh there was quite a bit about chase i
would say i i his whole high school
years his whole his views on religion i
mean we went down to a lot of stuff that
um was kind of too far off the spine of
the story with trevor lawrence but
i do think having an older brother that
was that different and there was no
sibling rivalry and it sort of
the unspoken effect of that was that
you're not going to
think football is all that matters to
anyone in the world because you're
living with someone you're close to
somebody who just has a moderate
interest in it and
and i think that did a lot for trevor
without anyone really trying to so his
older brother has a moderate interest in
football
is what you're saying yeah he has a huge
interest in his brother and
i don't think that he will be watching
games from uh
1pm until midnight on sundays no kidding
well let's not talk about him anymore
i don't think he's gonna take your job i
think you're safe no it's all good but
that's uh an interesting profile
um the hearts uh of jacksonville and
and all the fans there in in duval
county florida
are are counting on them and uh and
otherwise without without him her
urban meyer is going to be talking
college football on tv
this is the reason why the urban's
coming out of out of retirement
uh period did you talk to urban a lot i
did not talk
i did not talk to irvin for this and and
you know i
i did imagine what he thought while he
was reading these quotes because i don't
think you know urban's the kind of guy
that
you know he has a parking lot attendant
are you with us or against us you know
so that's that's sort of how we've used
the world but
right uh i kind of think lawrence will
actually be good for him because this is
somebody who's going to be a good kind
of liaison between the head coach and
and the other pros and as as urban makes
this adjustment and
uh i think that'll be good but yeah no
doubt they got different personalities
appreciate the time michael great peace
much appreciated lots of people talking
about it
great buzz two weeks right before the
draft i appreciate the call
thank you so much rachel you got it
that's michael rosenberg the author of
the piece on trevor lawrence that's got
a lot of people
talking hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here